(gentle music)
- [Narrator] Before the Spanish conquest
and before the Inca empire,
one group created the most important
South American civilization
at the time, the Chimu.
The Chimu civilization lasted
almost half a millennium,
from the year 1000 to around 1470 A.D.
At its height, the
kingdom spanned the region
between the southern border of Ecuador
and the Peruvian capital of Lima.
Much of the Chimus' success has
to do with their engineering
capabilities and artistry.
The Chimu were able to
construct massive structures,
particularly in the wealthy
capital city of Chan Chan.
Thousands of adobe structures,
such as palaces and temples,
were up to hundreds of feet long,
and some of those buildings
had walls about 30 feet high.
The Chimu also developed a
signature artistic style.
Craftsmen excelled at
producing luxury textiles
and elaborate metalworks.
They also created ceramics
that were distinctly Chimu
and often reflected aspects
of their coastal lifestyle,
such as fish, otters, and sea birds.
Despite advancements
in art and engineering,
the Chimu civilization eventually fell.
By around 1470 A.D., they were
conquered by the next great
Andean civilization, the Inca.
Centuries later, however,
the Chimu culture lives on.
In 1986, Chan Chan was designated
a UNESCO World Heritage Site,
helping preserve the legacy
of this ancient culture for
many more years to come.
(gentle guitar music)